we're expecting an announcement this
morning that could help free a man from
prison nearly 15 years after he was
convicted of murder Ricky Davis was
sentenced to 16 years to life for
second-degree murder in the 1985 killing
of a journalist named Jane Hilton but
now prosecutors in northern California
say new DNA evidence could help
exonerate him mola legi is following the
story mola what's this new evidence
well good morning Anthony source close
to the investigation tells CBS News the
genealogy may rule out Ricky Davis and
instead reveal the real killer in the
early morning hours of July 7 1985 54
year old newspaper columnist Jayne
Hilton was brutally stabbed to death in
this El Dorado Hills home Ricky Davis
his then girlfriend Connie doll and
Hilton's 13-year old daughter who all
lived in the house with Hilton at the
time said they found her and called 911
but the lack of evidence turned the case
cold and the identity of the killer went
unsolved for 14 years until November of
1999 we filed the complaint alleging one
count of murder Ricky Davis was tried
and eventually convicted in 2005 for the
murder and sentenced to 16 years to life
in prison
but was rewarding to finally reach a
completion investigators say DNA
evidence at the time connected Davis to
the murder along with a confession from
Dahl the day after the murder Dahl gave
a newspaper reporter a tour of the crime
scene she showed me a bloody handprint
on the wall and then she showed me where
she believes the body must have been
laid as if asleep is the way she
described it but in April of last year
with the help of the Northern California
Innocence Project newly tested evidence
revealed an unknown male DNA profile on
Hilton's nightgown and under her
fingernails he did not do it and I know
he didn't a judge reversed Davis's
murder conviction and he remained in
custody awaiting a retrial until now
similar genealogical testing used to
crack this case has also been used to
solve some of them
notorious murders in California he
favors quiet upper-class suburbs like
the Golden State killer Joseph James
D'Angelo who was accused of at least 50
rapes and 12 murders in California
between the 1970s and 80s and is being
used to hunt the infamous Zodiac killer
who boasted about killing as many as 37
people DNA expert Monte Miller anytime
we can't identify the criminal if we
could identify some of the criminals
relatives that might give us a very good
leg up on solving some of these crimes
well Davis is due back in court this
morning his lawyer tells us he hopes his
release from jail is imminent his Dale
record on the county website now lists
Davis as awaiting a removal order Tony
all right mola we'll be following you
thank you very much